[موسيقى]
هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا
بكم افادت وسائل اعلام روسيه بان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين زار مدينه ماريوبول في
مقاطعه دونياتسكا الخاضعه لسيطره القوات
الروسيه منذ شهر مايو ايار من العام
الماضي وقالت وسائل اعلام روسيه رسميه ان
بوتين التقى
جنوبيه روسيا بالقياده العليا لعمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وكان بوتين قد قام
يوم السبت بزياره مفاجئه الى شبه جزيره
القرم في الذكرى التاسعه لضمها الى روسيا
كما زار ميناء اسيفاستوبول الذي يعد مقرا
رئيسا للاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود
ميدانيا قال المتحدث باسم قياده العمليات
الشرقيه للقوات الاوكرانيه ان وحداته
قادره على تنفيذ عمليات لاخلاء المدنيين
والجرحى من العسكريين في مدينه باخموت
مشيرا الى استمرار المواجهات حول المدينه
قال سلاح الجو البريطاني مقاتل تابعه له
واخرى من القوات الجويه الالمانيه اعترضت
للمره الثانيه في اسبوع طائره عسكريه
روسيه قباله سواحل استونيا واشارت
بريطانيا الى ان الطائره العسكريه الروسيه
هي طائره نقل كانت ترافقها مقاتلتان من
طراز سوخوي 27
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
المباحثات التي قادتها بلاده نجحت في
تمديد اتفاق الحبوب بين الجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي
وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه انها ابلغت
الاطراف المشاركه في اتفاق الحبوب بتمديده
ل 60 يوما فقط حتى تتاكد من تنفيذه
بالكامل وكانت الامم المتحده اعلنت تمديد
الاتفاق واحطت جميع الاطراف على الالتزام
به لانه ساهم في تحقيق الاستقرار في
الاسواق العالميه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد تشامب
انه سوف يتعرض للاعتقال يوم الثلاثاء
القادم داعيا انصاره للاحتجاج وقد نفى
الادعاء العام في منهات ابلغت بموعد توجيه
التهم او الاعتقال بينما تحدثت التقارير
عن عدم التوافق بين القضاء ومحامي ترامب
لتسليم نفسه بدوره اتهم رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي المدعي العام باستخدام السلطه
للانتقام السياسي من
افادت وكاله يونهاب الكوريه الجنوبيه بان
كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا مارستيا فجر
اليوم وقال الاعلام الكوريه الشمالي ان
العمليه تاتي ردا على التدريبات الامريكيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه الجاريه حاليا ووصفت سول
لاطلاق الصاروخ بانه انتهاك واضح لقرارات
مجلس الامن الدوليه بدورها احتجت طوكيو
بشده على الخطوه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]